(choral music)
- Now, do I want
a classic grave
or one of those
tiny marble houses?
Ooh, I could see myself
in a little Taj Mahal
but less ethnic.
I can't predict if Indians
are still going to be trendy
in 100 years.
[gasps]
Beatrice, look!
I can get pink satin
in my casket.
Ooh, and a monogrammed pillow.
Beatrice, help me pick
my death pose.
Do you think this
is too old-fashioned?
Ooh, maybe arms by my side.
That's more modern.
Ooh, or maybe something like...
- What does it matter?
Worms are gonna
eat you either way.
- May I help you?
- Oh.
Uh...hi.
[giggles]
Yes, we'll take two
of your finest plots--
preferably in an area
that can accommodate a crowd.
- Wonderful.
Well, that should save me
the time of going through
this extremely extensive
waiting list.
[thud]
- [stammers]
Well, please.
I'm sure there's
something we can do.
It's very important
that I'm buried here.
- Oh, it's very important?
Well, why didn't you say so?
In that case, all you need to do
is travel backwards in time
and get your
great-great-great-grandparents
to have better families
and improve their bloodlines--
that is, if they can
even speak English.
- We don't know how
to travel backwards in time.
- You should tell that
to your dresses.
- That might hurt our feelings
if anything you said mattered,
but we're all just animals
on a cold, unfeeling rock,
hurtling our way toward
the inevitable godless abyss.
So...
it doesn't.
- Fine.
They're still old dresses.
- Please, you don't understand.
- Oh, no, child.
I do.
I simply don't care.
Anyway, there's nothing
to be done.
The cemetery
is completely booked.
We're only accepting
legacies now.
- Oh, uh, so legacies
are guaranteed admission?
- Yes. How else do you think
we ended up
with a mulatto district?
- [scoffs]
- Now, if you'll excuse me,
my 4:00 is here.
[laughing cordially]
Mr. Needham, welcome.
I see you've brought
your parents.
Come, let's go pick out
some plots
for your grandchildren.